alors sans crampons cette fois-ci mais
en chaussures au talon un autre genre de
sport le marathon d'un mannequin de mode
pendant les 5 jours les plus longs des
présentations de la mode automne-hiver
des grands couturiers yoga regarde
sa taille de 1 m 78 valorise ce fourreau
de velours
velours également pour ce bustier en
forme de cœur sur une jupe bouffante il
faut évidemment être très mince dans la
famille les gens disent que tu n'es pas
comme ça c'est comme si on faisait pas à
manger à la maison
maquillage coiffure habillage chez
Jean-Louis Scherrer
belle matière chaude
cachemire ou drap de laine
dernier coup d'œil du maître
couvert elles font ressortir le teint
remarquez le détail raffiné de broderie
sur la jupe et sur le tailleur
des épaulettes encore sur les vestes la
silhouette s'allonge
beaucoup de matières fluides comme cette
robe en soi qui colle à la peau
les marathons
avant le défilé
le
noir vert 88 89 mais aussi plus de
contraintes couleurs acidulés qui
donnent bonne mine
la mode de cela fait rêver les
mannequins aussi